[Applause]
doc we're ready
terrible places please
roll sound rolling roll cameras
a speed b speed c speed marker
and action i started making movies 15
years ago during my internal medicine
residency
as one does i was doing hiv disparities
research
amongst black women and that work turned
into a documentary
and i've been making movies ever since i
like to think of the movies and shows i
create as a kind of
visual medicine by that i mean i try to
put stories on the screen that address
large social barriers like racism in
america
gender inequities in ethiopia and global
health disparities and it's always my
hope that audiences
leave inspired to take actions that will
help people hurdle those barriers
visual medicine most of the time i live
and work in ethiopia the country i was
born
and currently i sit on the advisory
council of the ethiopian government's
job creations commission
now i'm sure you're wondering what a
doctor turned filmmaker
not economist is doing working with the
job creations commission
well i believe the creative industries
like
film and theater design and even fashion
can promote
economic growth and democratic ideals in
any country
i've seen it happen i've helped it
happen and i'm here to tell you
a little bit more but for some context
over the past 15 years ethiopia has had
amongst the fastest growing economies in
the world
this growth has led to a reduction in
poverty but according to 2018
numbers unemployment rates in urban
areas is around 19
with higher unemployment rates amongst
youth ages 15 to 29.
no surprise those numbers are even
higher among young women
like the rest of africa ethiopia's
population is young
which means as the urban labor market
continues to grow
people are aging into the workforce and
there aren't enough jobs to go around
so put yourselves in the shoes of any
government struggling to create enough
good paying jobs for a growing
population
what do you do i'm guessing your first
thought
isn't hey let's expand the creative
sector
we've been conditioned to think of the
arts as a nice thing to
have but not really as having a place at
the economic growth and security table
i disagree when i moved to ethiopia four
years ago
i wasn't thinking about these
unemployment issues i was actually
thinking about how to expand operations
of a media company i had co-founded
truthaid in the u.s ethiopia seemed like
an exciting new market for our business
by the end of my first year there i
joined a fledgling tv station that
exploded onto the media
scene tv as its first executive producer
and director of social impact
my job was to figure out how to produce
premium
original content in amharic the official
language
in a labor market where the skills and
education for film and tv was limited
there was really only one way we could
do it we would have to invest
heavily in training i was charged with
training the scripted drama team
and there was really only one way we
could do that on the job
paying my employees to make tv while
they learned how to make tv
their average age was 24 it was their
first job out of university and they
were eager to learn
we built a world-class studio and began
the first show we created as a project
of our training was a scripted series
with a powerful family at the center
called inheritance
the second show was ethiopia's first
teen drama
called yenya and was made in partnership
with the nonprofit girl effect
these shows turned the cast into
overnight stars
and went audiences over and the best
part of my job
quickly became running what was
essentially a content production talent
training
factory ghana would go on to make
several original content shows
including a health talk show i created
called huatei which translates into my
life
now this is obviously great for ghana
but we were doing something bigger
we were creating a model for how
training becomes employment
in a market where creating new jobs
especially as it relates to young people
is among the largest of demographic
challenges now you can't say you took a
bite
out of a large social problem like
unemployment if the jobs you create
only serve the interests of a single
private sector company
which is why i didn't stop at tv i
wanted the crews i had trained to have
exposure to international standard
production and was so thrilled when a
canadian irish co-production that i was
executive producing
came to ethiopia to shoot the feature
film sweetness in the belly
i contacted the ceo of state-owned
tourism ethiopia
to see if we could use this film as a
learning case study
for how government can support
filmmaking and filmmakers
the argument was films can promote
economic growth
and attract tourism dollars in two key
ways
by bringing production work to ethiopia
and more importantly by promoting
ethiopia
and its unique cultural assets to the
world
the latter taps into a nation's
expressive power
the government was incredibly receptive
and supportive and ended up providing
logistical and security support above
and beyond what a loan producer could
provide on her own
especially to such a large film crew
with their help we were able to complete
shooting the feature film
under very challenging conditions and i
was able to hire my tv crews so they
could deepen their experiences
and work alongside a world-class film
crew
this meant our employees could mature
and grow and move up their own
respective career ladders
not just in our company but in the
market at large
members of our crew have gone on to
start their own production companies
joined ad agencies communication firms
even other tv stations
to me this multiplier effect is what
it's all about
but the story gets better this was right
around the time the jobs creation
commission
hired me to conduct a diagnostic study
to assess the unmet needs
of sub-sectors like film visual arts and
design
and see what government could do to
respond to those needs
after we completed the study we made
policy recommendations to incorporate
the creative economy in the national
jobs action plan
as a high potential services industry
this led to a larger effort called
ethiopia creates
which is just beginning to organize the
creative industry entrepreneurs in the
sector so the sector can thrive
ethiopia creates recently organized a
film export mission to the european film
market where a team of ethiopian
filmmakers were able to pitch their
projects for potential financing
opportunities
now putting culture on the economic
agenda
is an incredibly important milestone but
truth of the matter is there's far more
at stake than just
jobs ethiopia is at a critical juncture
not just
economically but democratically it seems
like the rest of the world is at a
similar make or break moment
from my perspective on the ground in
ethiopia the country can go one of two
ways
either down a path of inclusive
democratic participation
or down a more divisive path of ethnic
divisions
if we all agree that the good way to go
is down the inclusive path
the question becomes how do we get there
i would argue one of the best ways to
safeguard democracy
is to expose everyone to each other's
stories
music cultures and histories and of
course it's the creative economy that
does that best
it's the sector that helps teach civil
society how to access new ideas that are
free of bias
artists have long found ways to inspire
inclusion
tell stories and make music for lasting
political impact
the late great american hero congressman
john lewis understood this when he said
without dance without drama without
photography
the civil rights movement would have
been like a bird without wings
okay we're back
now imagine how much more effective
music films and arts would be
if artists had good paying jobs and the
government supported them
in this case economic growth and
democratic growth go hand in hand
i think any government that views arts
as a nice thing to have
as opposed to a must-have is kidding
itself
arts and culture and all of their forms
are indispensable for a country's
economic and democratic growth
it's precisely countries like ethiopia
that can't afford to ignore the very
sector that has the potential to make
the greatest civic impact so just as
john lewis understood that the civil
rights movement could not take flight
without the arts
without a thriving creative sector that
is organized
like an industry ethiopia's future or
any other country at its moment of
reckoning
cannot take flight the economic and
democratic gains these industries afford
make the creative economy essential to
development and progress
thank you
everybody
you